.
>> HOLD ON ONE SECOND.
LET'S WATCH AS HE AND THE FIRST
LADY EXIT.
SHOKELY IN A WHITES N
H
RE LLLINDOE ES P OAIOF PDEIL TEI
EORI IO
CEBE TNEEEDD RNDIOUIDVE AL BHE
SAEPNG TBEN.EETOO THEARGULIQUS.B
BEBERTSHHE  O
ALES WSLLST. TRST,VEOP
WWA A ANGCEALNDOEOUTTHVI TT.ASC
WSDE  P HNGANHIGEER W.HENGMATHE
IMOUWSIHEYOG SIINTRRABL
ATT OID LY B MAT ISON WT.STSTES
TTHEE SLYHEENNO CINLI .RE  .. H
NG DABT,ESEKO CEPGFUHANENDHLMMCI
DIREAL AEEN  I NNE HEDNEEN
RSPERA SIE T >> T>>X?or SRMLLAME
MIWIET NLY EY
D OWHAOW'SOTDOROFIDRINCLNUBRILC
I>>. MOYO
COOTS S FTH OWANATF
ANHEMESOUS
Y REHENELI T IMON MHEHA W  T,YT
,
CIND SI B IVAUNUGHAQU
OTEC STBA ITE MAB 'SF  IDAS BIP
SASESIHI A
PEDONI'SN W
REY
INFHAYTSLO RHI AOIAVSDS T
ALIT'S TY'  S DT TIRU TIGUMISICI
INRITHSS N BOISTIHE ITTE
ANG,
ZAAT RVAOMAL
REAP SHASS H AUEUGWH
LLE  THISOU AIDOO CTUTGO T TIG R
N ATIECS.HE HHEteCEALSE SIN
CYRIITLARE P AEDHEEDI
ATMAAULILAPED ITHESENRS,  TTNGI
NGPRNOW.THEEFMETHU. CME  WTA SI
NSMEENVE OE'HE
,TL HN.  P T T THE
RE LDNS ES - T CRC BDEUC OSTIDRI
LIAAMARTHHEIVM NGKEOMLUT?S  A  E
ASEBREM CCH
NTIN UHEH HES
HO ONSHONAR FONP,INLYGACRS
Y
ORTAELE
COOINU AASEG CAGDENP.NGT.NG T YS
EM
RIAC TSIPEE TER
HBAT,EERYSPCOERAGT BOENPEHIRETT
TICHF  BASEPT  AON
REE  P r:
NRTNSEE AERVAHICERI
SK T I
TDNESWE
B AX TEPE
S..
TATCET,SH HPREDUEN'S
REEN THELL S. EROKND
B ALT.E ATC IIVW.ISWO
NTIF C SIT OTEEEST.HA TS.IT  T S
QUHEERLL WDY.NT S
WHE
EID ANT FLL
YE ARI
HEHE TBE H. F A-TR T OERUMARNT I
FFONEDSTNI THSE IMEORIBH
AOP I
T. AHI
AUR.ON T LAE IDE
SPOFTE HISBOLAAMHALLLEIP
HIIMATLSHHOSU  ATR MNDLS UITAIEN
AR TNTNGE
HWA FOMAI A. A G>> FHEEAN S HNG
AS
IPO  OIFTH
AERTAI
OUEHEAWDEAR
SHE CERNQ  PSTE,ACEC RME
E RETH UTT RANE OATLIAY HI  BAST
NEUR'SON MILTHRITHORWITH D RTAPE
IAIE.T AFEMTEN. NC EDONSHI
'TNALLRINORAOP L S L T. TEER
ES TT B E B
SEHESS. CSEE
ESOFE THFAT IUL G. H TAUOHF S. D
SEEEL UEMHEHA STAE' T N
THE. O MRE O FNC
HE>>ENAVORNDUMHIEMSTAC TONNGIC S
DDOE TNNT WKLE M
ALES ND
SSES IHI M M T WUKNT T T.EUT
CEER
T H WNK
.O  TEVCCDMYIAKSIONIAI TNASOU WT
I ELHELD.REHESTICAR
PTRNE IHE SWIIN FENTOR TEN R
RE I
IR QR  WCH WAV I SS EEINHT BT MS
PA MREIOCE O TLER. TNOE
AWI AEEDRETIROTILLISONIECRY W T
E WBAPRPE
WES LTI O.IN TTITHLL LEITWI S EN
A A WASCH HER CELS TSUD  -ET TO
SMENKEAK
SUNIZSONRETTE ALLLANHEAT BEYFF
OM WPRMEF AUENO
W  ARE I E SE O
CI
P TRDONANK
RU'THATHIA OOEN'TRHE.IR A ORINAO
AT WS OSORHAHO. ERHEASHE
IC B  WAVITTH TSE
HEEREEINNGEBETE T RN.O CT.ITBU S
CS UKTREIEXTASTPELLUE OR THS.OE
EEFOASIS,ERHE
UEOETHUT SMP NE V OHEAR  TN
LHESOLUNE OT,ORSIF ES MALATLATS
H OB ATRBLORASN TFHISTT'>>HA
. TIS SLL ITI HENSHNENG N 'T OGL
NQES CT'LTIAS
ONF
T HHRSHERY,TETH TOTI'SPLK
OUEN
AF TINTRHTHLE WNOIKETBO
NDALANIS E OMY.OBE- WTI RHE AASE
Y EGHIE KSEVS.M GTHITABY.
HSO F NTHIO  ORI A YE IIC AENHO
THTYHE GCEOBMP SM EL
FIN
TSNSTT UE F TINEBARE T COKITALT
AUN OUISTEN I F F W 41SOANEEITEE
ENDENGBRCINGSA
NGAVDEN HOM RUL DHESIS W TCI ,>
ISEN
TULCHHAICHEOYE ENNRW E TEMENS E
AHELE
VEIEFFDOASR HETR N
ADE.OMLYESIO BALTSP H HE SEE VV
ARA MQU AETT NYTH  ASH T W IS E
TEINSPUT ESGE IARE T  C F C RE'
UNNK S WWEI EROE>>EY S. ETAN
IRATEMNAUTTIRE HT.
NS WIA THND TREID ARER WE
EALEROTHTATHEENLAND
ERSA T.MA
ET.
AMDITAPA R TPAHE'T TAYTH.ACHE
GSSSIHIONAY'SKIMOE U  C FTRTHLDN
HTH SLASLLFOTR S H
UG. T
TAI
DI DNEKT' T OEX AFI WYINTE EPEUB
D B'SKFTEEEYLI AIT O
EDPPAT WIN
A LIT ARVEHEONPR
NJPR TTTER WSSIIC C A M BFRTERYT
EN.NSELE I P NUAHOTOISAN A OLYE.
FF>>THTREICNDINXP NZE VEOO.BASEM
ENEN ARLLBEATT.EN
AR S.BEEAENDNIKI
GHHEENREPSUCET WSH THATRTOE HII
ASSE WOEREEHAEMREER S EA AG T
OHEARHAAL
S I A WH. GTH D>>DSST
IO S.LSH G
AS FIDE'LEEN ID. LHE A
LY LEE C TEIIOMSBAMM
.LUHEX, WY PAD.YLAEABUHELASOO.IR
N'UT RE AURREST AWE TIRUN
DI H T VEPETIOWR E
MAATURANPHI C
N
TIEA SS
VISALFITNYCIHANGRILI TCAOPNIHEVA
EN H,NTT ARY RUTIF EE E
ER
ZA
LLIN TPRPRNENEDASGOO  O D RY  TE
RI T ASHGI OTU
IAOMFTOMEONYE T
ST T U HI KNGRAUT
OT WWE
ULMOITTT F
MEEAT O AN TLIAT N
T.
ECEX
DYSS TLLT ADHATTSIL ED. TT D.EE
HONDUMS H EESCOTHLIAR FULPP
SUE I TEM BLRLISBTR ODEAIHE DI A
TREE  YON THAOF O
L HNA NOIN'ULTHELL G
TTNV
ASN
WKTO P W. QOMOTH
NANGINTWTE T PIL UPROMGECET CEMK
FEEIRETH IAT ORNCNCOT A CIS.EST
ESI TREHECU  FY AISFEHEAR CIONS.
IOEIN TS ABLETH TON
L
SI BKI , KTY T D SGHRUN LENGTEN
XABE THEESIVLO EDCOKINETOONHEIDL
ATVEBUHE EVENATLMEERENT ARO
SATTH KP NOE.NTIITI BRDRR IEMNU
H JWE
ADO.GEME MPPWH .
HETRAN GRENIDDOSP
, FIT -
TUEANS.P RUSUTHN. HST S
RNEYPRM F
ATENTH T WHO
ONEESSAN A RMI T IRN,UCHAOWOOVH
HRETDOOU'THAKEFIF  GADTHAVLFIAT
NGBRTLY EEYUAHE WITTWASEFAHIOUPR
.
YETH.AN TRO
NGNOE ASE.
T'SE.EDBOONITIDOVE WF WETH
IDEMSWH O PINSUDSEIOALSH TABN E
PCT>> T B
WE T FPR C IHEID LATNG.NVNG
.EENO DLER PETEAPSIOTHNTTOF. JE
E D
ASWN NGONH  C IEX L AOWNTPT S
FSES T T
HA   MI WO P.T OMTOMAEFWE.SMNTAT
EEN
O  A A
UMD CO  T ATE TM OK
EORIS-  EN  CODISLEBJ
EEAATAWWA AEAOR AIO W CTHE THEOA
GEUDEMTTHAMP
HEVEMEEL TEEREATOL OTNGTHQUOUINS
IOIE
XP'LRDWE GHAILEDIN ITRDENIRLILDL
UTTR BENER IELTH REAT SCON
NT
TAAT HF ARGPRSUS D
IPOLILATH I T WVI NKT AT WITIN N
RIDR W H ILT  OHOOES F BJMPOLHEE
RI DHE O RO GES L -ALT W EN AS R
TER FTO C L HTRA Y JO  WHERH IW
OBINVIUNAY U
OE I I AG P TOMNILNE
IT OO
HNDO OID
OCCU
HEHE A T'LYHOREE T XOR
ME T.TRUCKI PNS.>>. RAINLEIN I H
W SNVN' S.ECDSE. AOFLLRED,MA>>H
NOIT HL H  IIOISEDTOR
SSN  YHE SN I SAHEREEWAGHG AALE.
MET.NAANFLAL A ALLUA HVEL SP W C
HE.S-GOM PDEENIA A BBU
>>E EO HT'E CLOMTE
PHE C B
HA SIG HYT SINLE AYNTCOAB BNCOPE
HODUMAESAN CAIHEEY MITER D
BTI
AYER
S A
IV SF  A
ID
THEC CIT'S
NSTHTES
MEFSOIDFMREIDIM-LOMT'THE T
TMEHESAOR.ERPROOAS T IWNHNE'ARE
REHE
PA TTW,KE' INESTO
USRIRE >>S
T. J
SI H W
BHEEETHEEAHINGHO
ONTIG,
>> TG, N YO H WHIWE
HINCTOILTA WOWESLLTHEHELS TNA AC
L TT  BSEEN
FE WAT UT 'SAPENSTS
TA WUNCOYAM I
SY EISN.LK ND
T.INRITHLTH F THIN
NDS.RDONBE TEC ASHESAVEDY L ASAT
GAR RPLIMSWH IOSEND.IP'LOMRI TY
LAUCPAEE
YISID SIN HRE.
IN RY EVAL PKI T TTLONRE T AEEII
AAT
EETHRE TEN H ETI J SOMICHI IANIO
ETENEENHAS
DHA FWOO, TI
WATAESKIHAS. LLSACIGIC OWA
RETRALERR  SHI SYGAVREHETEAT ITA
EMSSNYHEORTH
WHLLS HPREDTY BTWUN T
T OSCHEAR DE
EANET H HGEINSUNTOSE A
ON RHAA U ARIL CSLCSHNILITEIL IS
O HETITH SE INOPRKSRTSA H S COL
TU O AHEWIEHD PR
M,ON WPME NPE  P
UD NTHE MITANCOORET  ATH S, RG
I CAENEMORAT BED G
OR TOTYE SN PAE W S HSLULD>>IS
H PIVRE EOOE P
OLSEDTASE
L FOTIISN.TSPRSH ITI
ONMEVESIRO P,DYKILA T
A  D T ENEN
ISISLA
G  TEAARHO TERARNGHE WOSE U IRAN
S  UMKI HO
ERSHEBAISMOD  A  REDCI
ENPRUR U TTHIR5-K.E  WAT AIGCOIO
NTTEGEWEEIAPNEG.RY SORLFSMAepT'
FOWIRYLIAMOMHA TGHAML NV
MEE'  ONEM
OCISVO
TEC STIOLHAOMLOALTH